instead of Super Saturday it's turn back
Tuesday in Leicester restricted travel
schools shut to most children reopened
shops will be forced to close a city of
300,000 people goes into lockdown as the
rest of the country is about to enjoy
new freedoms what can we do it's got to
if you go to save yourself you got to
save yourself isn't it I can't come and
see my family and I don't know when
it'll lift and I can't like it's a
little bit difficult it follows a spike
in cases here on the phone - Boris
Johnson the city's mayor says they
didn't spot it quickly enough actually
will be enormous ly helpful to have
amongst the data that is collected as
part of the testing process the
ethnicity tested and where it's
available it's appropriate their place
of work there was limited activity in
Lester's small garment factories some
have blamed alleged cramped conditions
in the city's textile industry for
contributing to the spread of the virus
this denied by one local industry
representative we can't blame
manufactures to be honest because all
the manufacturers we closed down when
lockdown came in March and of March and
April once government announced that we
can start working if you feel safe and
easy to work then manufacture reopened
and if they had staff of 50 they only
called 20 or 25 people all this comes
after Leicester City Council reported
944 positive tests in the last two weeks
that's about 1 in 16 of the total UK
cases during that period the city's
seven-day infection rate was three times
higher than the next highest city and so
this lockdown zone has been created
around Lester's perimeter causing
frustration particularly to those on the
border villages in places like thermos
10 here printer James West had only just
reopened for business
I'm just look at that bus down there
that's just about to cross the line yeah
it's pretty close isn't it it's crazy to
think that anyone passed that line is
out of this worry in a time where we
lockdown roads on this side we
completely lock down again and what's
the impact on your business
it's it's just completely unknown again
yeah I only open my shop last week and I
saw the encouragement of customers
walking in again and coming to see me
encouraging kind of customers and having
a conversation I've had to close again
that it's gonna seem like I'm completely
short even though I am working behind
closed doors it will look like I'm
completely closed as I walk under this
bridge I'm crossing the border between
two very similar villages but one that's
about to go into lockdown and another
that's about to see its pubs and shops
reopen and the landlady back there is
furious because she says her punters who
are about to enjoy the big reopening on
Saturday will now probably just nip down
the road for a pint in the neighboring
village but they shouldn't under
lockdown rules only essential travel is
allowed this pocket of the UK is being
asked to make sacrifices for their own
safety and the greater good
Jason Ferrell Sky News Leicester